Okay. So, um,
the second part of the last lecture
introduced the idea of Alkenes and we were
talking about the stability
of Alkenes sis versus trans,
uh, and the effect of substitution. Uh,
we'll go on with that today and
then go on to addition mechanisms,
which is the characteristic
reactivity of alkenes.
So if we look at the, uh,
stabilities of these, uh,
c six alkene isomers that
we talked about last time,
we showed how you could get the numbers
for those from the Nis t website.
Uh, it's also possible, uh,
to get them from this, uh,
uh, book by Pedley. That's the
one that, uh, Professor Weinberg,
who's a big expert on this,
I recommended to me as a good source.
So here's the heat of
formation of the, uh, of the,
the, the, uh,
straight chain with the double
bond and that number one position,
uh, what does he to formation?
What's that? The heat relative to
the energy of this
molecule compared to what
the heat of formation
you read,
rehearse from last semester.
Mary,
it's not the heat of battle
causation.
How do you measure such things?
How do you measure the heat of a molecule?
Yep.
Yeah, yeah. No, that's, that's how
that was the way that you got the
heat of formation of carbon atoms from
graphite and Lebron,
but that only needed to be done once
to get where carbon atom is relative to
graphite.
Then you need to know the Ma,
the energy of molecules relative
to graphite. How do you do that?
But that's a very difficult
thing to do with them. Do to
break the bonds of graphite, Matt, do
you have an idea? Combusts graphite.
You burned them,
right?
You compare them to see oh two so
you take your molecule and burn that.
We talked about this last semester,
you burn graphite,
you also burn h two so you can
get a hydrocarbon. How much,
what's the energy of your
compound compared to the
amount of energy that was in
hydrogen and carbon of
graphite? Okay, so anyhow,
the heat of formation is,
is a minus a 10 or a little
bit more kilocalories per mole.
That means it's that much more stable
than the elements would be in their
defined standard state. Okay. Now,
if you'll look at it
for the CIS three Hex,
seen the double bond
beginning on the third carbon,
it's a little bit more stable.
Right?
And that doesn't surprise you because
we've talked about having a more carbons
as opposed to hydrogens on a,
on a double bonded carbon,
uh, makes the, makes the
compound more stable.
That is that the ch bonds are not as,
don't profit as much from the change in
hybridization to cc bond seemed to do
okay.
Now if you have the Trans Isomer,
it's still more stable by about
one and a half kilo calories.
I don't know whether you had a chance to
look at the problems yet. Probably not.
They were for Wednesday, uh, to look at
the generalities, but you find that, uh,
the Trans isomer is about one and a
half kilocalories more stable than this.
This,
can you think of any explanation for that,
Amy?
Right,
right.
That they run,
the groups run into one another.
It's a stearic effect when they're assist.
That's worth about one and a half
kilocalories per mole. Okay. Now if you,
if you make three carbon carbon
bonds from the double bond, uh,
incidentally there's a table
that has those in it too. In the,
in the Jones book, if you put
three carbons on the double bond,
then it's more stable still.
And obviously if you put four,
it's a little bit more stable still.
Now, if we come back and look at the,
at the, uh, at correcting
for strain, which would,
which was what we attributed the
difference between CIS and Trans, uh, two,
we find that there's 3.6 kilocalories
of molecular mechanics strain in the sis
and 2.5 and the trans. So it's
what you said Amy, that's the melt.
Like molecular mechanics explains
it in terms of a stearic effect.
Okay, so the average then
for those two is about there.
And now if we make strain corrections
for the other molecules as well,
calculate the strain
by molecular mechanics.
There's 2.8 kilocalories
of strain calculated there,
2.6 and 7.7 and the one that has
four carbons on the double bond.
And now you notice something
interesting about the trend.
Once you've corrected for strain,
what do you notice? All right,
it's almost exactly linear
according to the number of CC bonds,
right?
So you get,
you gain in stability about two and a
half kilocalories per mole every time you
substituted the Cah with a CC,
right?
Keeping the same number of carbons and
hydrogens in the molecule discussing
isomers of one another.
Cause of course it makes no sense to
compare heats of formation for molecules
that are not isomers from
one of one another, right?
You're comparing apples with
oranges. Okay? So you get,
so that could be due
to this hybridization,
it could in part be due to
hyper conjugation that we
talked about before the,
uh, and we'll talk a little
bit more about it later.
Now let's think about the thermo
chemistry involved in Alkie hcl reaction.
So here's Hcl plus and how keyed to give
the edition product where h is added
the one carbon and cl to the other.
So notice we've converted a single bond
and a double bond on the left into three
single bonds on the right. Is that
likely to be favorable or unfavorable?
What's the energy of a double
bond compared to two single bonds?
That's what we've done here.
Do you remember from our table and
we looked at in the first semester,
how much?
The second is the second bond of a
double bond worth as much as the first,
more or less, it's worth less. Okay.
So if we look back at that table
that we looked at last semester, uh,
and, and put actual numbers
to these, to these, uh,
bonds that we've drawn here,
uh,
we see that the hydrogen chloride bond
is worth 103 kilocalories per mole.
The double bond carbon carbon double
bond is 146 so there's 249 that we're
losing in the starting material.
So how much do we gain in the product
making the three single bonds?
So there's 104
and [inaudible] 83
and 81 okay,
so two 68 in other words,
it's profitable by 19 kilocalories
per mole to do this edition.
And we talked about this before when
we were talking about chain reaction,
addition of Hcl, right?
Or, or Hbr, Ahi and so on,
all of the war exothermic
by about that much.
So it's favorable by 19
kilocalories per mole.
Uh,
now we could also look more specifically
at these compounds by using that data
that's in a table that we access last
time from National Institute of Science
and technology to look at the
actual heats of formation of these,
of these particular molecules
in the gas phase. That is, uh,
before we were just looking at average
bond energies to get an order of
magnitude idea of what's going on or
better than an order of magnitude.
But these,
these now will give us the precise values
and where we said it was 19 before,
now we see that for this specific
set of compounds, it's 14 a half.
But we were about right,
it was a good guest before.
Now suppose that, uh, so this
reaction should go to the right,
but we've already talked about a
reaction that goes to the left.
What reaction would that be?
The one that starts on the
right and he goes to the left.
That's the elimination reaction. And he
two reaction goes from right to left.
What's the difference?
Why could we talk if this,
if this equilibrium lies to the right,
how could we have spent all this time
in the last quarter of the course?
Talking about reactions going the
other way is not uphill and energy.
What reagents do you use to
do the elimination phase?
A strong base, right? Like hydroxide.
So let's see what happens if
we put hydroxide into the mix.
Okay, so we had it acid,
we get addition, right?
And it's favorable by 14 kilocalories
per mole in this particular case.
But if we put hydroxide in there,
now what will it react with?
Well, it it, we,
we know we talked about how it pulls
off the Proton at the same time chloride
leaves and the two reaction. But if all
we're doing is study in Thermo Chemistry,
we could look at where it is in
the product, in the balance of the,
of the two sides of the equation.
So what it does on the left is take
the proton awaits wage away from HCL,
right? To give water and chloride. Now,
hcl is a much stronger acid than water is.
So that's a very favorable process to
take the proton away from hcl and to put
it on hydroxide. And
in fact, we could, uh,
find out how different it is by
looking up at that same table,
the proton affinities of o,
h minus and chloride.
And we find they differ by
19 kilocalories per mole.
So adding hydroxides stabilizes the
left side of this equation by 19
kilocalories per mole,
and now it's favorable to go the other
way by four and a half kilo calories per
hole. Okay, so we had base,
you do elimination,
you go the other way.
Now are these really the
reverse of one another?
Do we just run the machine
backwards to get, uh,
elimination as a PA as or to get addition
as compared to the elimination we
talked about before?
Or is it a different mechanism?
Because the conditions are
different. This is done. The,
the elimination was done in
the presence of strong base.
The addition has done
in the presence of acid.
So you might not be able to run
the machine backwards. Right?
So incidentally,
here's a problem for you to look out for
Wednesday to use the PKA values for hcl
in h two o to estimate here.
Here I looked it up actually the
proton affinities and I s t and got 19
kilocalories per mole.
But you could have done the same thing
out of your head or out of a simple table.
Does anybody remember
what the PKA of Hcl is?
The exam is Friday. I
realize that. Scrub that now
anybody remember about what it is?
It's about,
I think it's minus eight, isn't
it? And how about the PKA of water?
Negative 16 so from that difference
you can calculate what the,
what the energy of that reaction would be.
So try it from that difference
and see if you can do it.
That's a good exercise for you.
But other than the rate,
we have the question of the
addition to the back of aneurysm.
Is it the reverse of the
two or Iwan mechanism?
Okay.
So we're going to talk about addition to
Alkenes and we've already done that to
a certain extent.
We talked about the SOMO mechanism,
the free radical chain edition of Hbr.
And you remember what that is,
that a bromine atom ads to
give the more stable radical,
which then attacks HBR taking off the
hydrogen atom to give the the product,
it gives that product and there's
a reference in the textbook,
gives that product not the one above.
Right.
And it doesn't give that one,
it's Riggio selective.
And remember we called this
anti Markovnikov, right?
Markovnikov had the idea as
we talked about last time,
that the carbon that has more
substituents gets more, right.
So if you had,
if you had two methyl groups already
on one of the double bonded carbons,
it would be the one that
gets the bromine that, uh,
that the hydrogen goes to the other one.
But this is anti Markovnikov.
It does the, does the opposite. Okay.
So we've already talked about that.
And the key feature in the regio selection
is getting the more stable carbon
radical.
Okay.
But it's also conceivable that there
could be a homo Lumo mechanism,
a concerted one where the new
group comes up to the double bond.
And the part the partners
just exchange like this.
Suppose you had h two to react with
with the carbon carbon double bond.
A very exothermic reaction,
right?
So you could just shift electron pairs
like that and perform the edition.
Right. Now let's look at the orbitals
that would be involved in that.
Uh, what's, what's the homo
of the CC? Double Bond.
Ellen. Hi. Okay.
And the,
and the Lumo is Pi Star now.
So let's try to bring the whole,
the Lumo in the homo of the
h two down on top, right.
Looked good to mix homo and Lumo.
What do you call that situation?
Ro.
They're out of phase. They're, in fact,
there's a specific word to talk about
things that don't overlap for this
cemetery kind of reason.
Remember what it is?
They're orthogonal on her access,
right? So there could be no,
there's no mixing of Homo, of one
with Lumo or the other. Of course,
you could shift them right?
So that they mix, right?
But then there's nothing to be gained
because on the left you're mixing,
filled with filled. That's repulsive.
And on the right, the orbitals are empty.
There's nothing that has that,
whenever energies are
available for those orbitals.
So you can't do this reaction,
you can't just bring a B signal bond
down on top of a double bond and change
partners cause the symmetry is wrong of
the orbitals. They won't mix that way.
You can't draw those two arrows.
However,
it turns out that if you use certain
catalysts in particular metals like
platinum,
they make it possible to do this
because the platinum gets involved,
it gets its orbitals involved in
there can be favorable overlap.
And we'll be talking about that pretty
soon. You see that in the Jones book?
That's in chapter 10.
Okay.
So that would be a concerted reaction
where you make and break bonds at the same
time.
But it's also possible to do it step wise.
That's why the reactions are called
electrophilic because you have, uh,
an acid,
for example,
HBR and the homo attacks,
the sigma star Lumo attacks the
Proton to give off bromide, right?
And then the bromide can attack the,
uh,
can attack the intermediate cad I.
And so it's a two step reaction.
So the initial reaction is the
reaction of an electro file,
something that wants the
electrons a low Lumo.
The sigma star of Hbr is the reagent
that reacts with the Double Bond.
Okay. And notice that that one
works for any hydrogen. Hey,
do you remember all the hydrogen halides
where exothermic for their addition to
the double bond, but only HBR would
work by the top mechanism here,
the Somo because both steps are
exothermic to compete with termination,
right? Whereas any of the
hydrogen hail lights we'll do,
we'll do this step wise
electrophilic or reaction.
And notice in this case that it does
follow Mark Cuban to Coffs rule.
It's not that one.
It's the,
it's the Markovnikov where bromide goes
to the more substituted carbon and it
goes there because that carbon
is more stable in the inner,
that carbon cat die in this
more stable as an intermediate.
Okay. So that's stuff that
mostly we've mentioned before.
Now let's think about the orbitals
and where they should get attacked.
So here's ethylene and alkeen and we
can look at the surface potential to see
the energy of a proton on
the Vanderwall surface.
So a proton likes to be up above where
the double bond is and it doesn't like to
be around where the hydrogens
are, right? So this,
this electrostatic,
a feature of the surface of the
molecule is important in positioning the
fragments before they begin to react.
But new bonding requires mixing or,
but also not just positioning
things electrostatically hey,
so we should look at
the homo and the Lumo.
So the Lumo is,
is this a Pi Star or a beetle?
And the homo is the Pi orbital,
right?
So the addition,
as we've said to alkenes is electrophilic.
It goes after the Pi electrons,
the high homo.
So the proton with its low vacant orbital
electrostatically likes to be up on
top.
That's the best place to be.
If you're on the surface of the molecule
and when it's there, it can overlap, uh,
with this, uh, uh, Pi Star
that, but this Pi orbital.
So in the various textbooks you have,
you can read about this
electrophilic addition to alkanes.
I guarantee you there are
all these sections in there,
one about hydrogen haylight
edition by our plus by the cat eye.
And intermediate what we just
talked about on the previous slide,
there'll be discussion
of the regio chemistry,
which end the h plus adds two to give the
more stable cad I and intermediate and
there'll be discussion of hydration
where instead of the x minus being the
things adds to the h plus it's
the solvent water, right? The,
the unshared pair on oxygen can attack
the cat eye on as well and then lose a
proton so that it's Oah that
goes on instead of x minus.
So you can be reading that in your texts.
And this just to show an
example is from the uh,
uh,
lecture that I mentioned was given by
Professor Siegel last year where he talks
about how you can do this Markovnikov
addition chloride going into the more
substituted hi.
Ooh.
Going into the more substituted are
going to the more substituted when it's
clean, right? That is when you don't
have free radical initiators there.
Okay. So all of these form
by Proton first going here,
right to get this more stable
cad on intermediate. Uh,
and in this case with
dilute sulfuric acid,
it was water that came on to do this.
Okay.
And that mechanism is
shown here incidentally,
a on the exam,
the,
remember the last question was to draw
very careful curved arrows and everything
I give,
I put this up in part to give you fellow
feeling because we graded that very
rigorously.
When you draw a curved Arrow where
due to denote electron pair shifts,
where do you start the Arrow,
where the electrons are in the starting
material and where do you end the,
the point of the Arrow,
where are those electrons
are in the product?
Sometimes they will be on and Adam
become an an eye on or become an unshared
payer.
Sometimes they will be between two atoms
because you're forming a new bond and
if you want to be thinking
really clearly about it,
you should draw those arrows clearly.
That's why I asked it
that way in the question.
But notice that professor Siegel
here in drawing some of these arrows,
drew it going onto the hydrogen,
he drew the x minus going onto the carbon
where I would expect you to draw this
curved Arrow ending between x and the
carbon and to position those two things
that are going to react
with one another in the,
in your drawing such that they're close
enough to one another that that makes
sense to end the Arrow between them,
not to have it off here in the Arrow
terminating in space just because it's
halfway between. So that's a lesson
that I hope that will become clear.
Okay, so this shows the case
of water intervening. Okay.
So, uh, there,
there are sections of the books about
the addition to hydrogen highlights about
regio selectivity,
about the intermediate cat ions that
are involved about cad and stability and
about cad. I and rearrangements, and I'll
talk about a few of those things here,
but you can review them in
your book as well. Okay.
First about cad I and stability.
I took this from the text we use
a couple of years ago by Loudon,
so he shows primary,
secondary and tertiary cad ions.
How many carbons are substituted on them
and says of the stability of Carbo cat
ions that tertiary is more stable than
secondary is more stable than primary.
This of course is the explanation
for Markovnikov cough orientation.
Now we can look at the rationale for that.
A rehearse it once again,
hyper conjugation says if you have high,
it's better to have a carbon on the carbon
cad ion with its hydrogen or whatever
else it's bonded to.
Then to have just the hydrogen and the
reason it's better is that there's some
kind of Hobo,
it's in position to have its electron
stabilized by that unusually low energy
Lumo the one associated
with the positive charge,
the vacant orbital on carbon and in the
case of hydrogen there are no electrons
to be stabilized. Those are our thoughts
funnel to this. But in this case,
the bought the sigma electrons
that are in the bond,
even though they aren't particularly high,
can interact with a really
unusually low orbital and,
and get some stabilization.
So we've talked about this before,
this hyper conjugation.
And it can be denoted by
writing a resonance structure,
which has a double bond
between the carbons and an h
plus or are plus if it's an
art group out there.
The other rationale for this order of
cad ions stability is bond energies.
And we've talked about this several times,
changing ch to CC bonds when they,
when you have this specially,
uh, advantageous sp square
hybridisation of the carbon.
But those are theory
and it's different to,
to know what the evidence is that they
actually have that order tertiary more
stable than primary.
So the first part is the rationalization.
Now we have to say,
where do we actually get the evidence
that their stability is that way? Right?
And several people on the exam,
uh, when asked for evidence,
provided theory,
rationale like this rather than
actual numbers they have where,
where the evidence comes from.
So to get evidence you
have to compare something.
So you could compare, uh, products or,
or transition states that is,
you could look at reactivity if you have
a very unstable cat die and you would
expect it to be more reactive.
Right?
So that would be one way that you
could do it. Another way would be,
uh,
compare with the starting alkene you,
if it's easier to put a proton on that
will for that would indicate that the cat
died and you're leading to is more stable,
right?
The cat ions uphill and energy typically.
But if it's a more stable cat eye
and it should be easier to form.
So the reactions where you protonate the
alkene and should be easier or in the
reactions, we were just talking
about the, the sn one substitutions,
the ease of losing the anti in
order to generate the leaving group.
That is to say in order to
generate the carbon cat eye,
it should be easier when
the cat ion is more stable.
So we could do either of those
or we could compare directly,
compare the cat ions with one another,
right.
To see which one is more stable.
Now here's a table taken
from the textbook, uh,
which gives a table of the heats of,
of carbon cad ions,
uh, in the gas phase. So they're very
hard to make in the, in the gas phase.
And it says secondary vinyl cad ions
are more stable than primary vinyl cat
ions.
Now what's the basis for that here
in the table?
What's the basis for saying that secondary
vinyl cat ions are more stable than
primary vinyl cad ions?
Yeah,
well,
we look up there and we see a primary
vinyl cad ion is in fact that the highest
energy of any of these right.
And the secondary vinyl cad iron is
also pretty high. I mean, it's, it's,
it's substituted, which, you
know, it's, it's secondary,
which should make it better
and indeed it is better. Okay.
So it says it's better by 54
kilocalories per mole in the gas phase.
Okay.
No, there's a problem with this,
with using this table in this way.
And the problem is compared to what?
Yeah.
Is this really saying that a primary
vinyl cad ion is more stable than a
secondary vinyl cat on compared to what
these heats of formation?
What are they compared to?
Yeah,
so this is the energy of the vital
cat eye and compared to what?
Yeah,
what's the heat of formation?
Hello?
Th th that's the heat of combustion.
It could have been heat of combustion.
We would add something to these
to get heat of combustion. Right.
But it's actually what's
given as a heat of formation.
Perfect.
Yeah. Compared to carbon and graphite
and hydrogen and h two gas at standard
temperature and pressure and so on.
That is compared to the elements
in their standard states.
But notice that there are different
numbers of atoms in these things.
They're not ice of one another.
So it's not that you can convert
one to the other and say that that,
that the heat, that this heat difference
shown here takes one to the other.
There you're comparing apples and oranges,
they're just not the same thing.
If you want to compare
with heats of formation,
they have to be things that are ice
verse of one another where you know their
energy relative to one another rather
than relative to something completely
different. Different
numbers of Adams. Okay,
so this particular table doesn't help you
at all directly in figuring out except
that there might be some
cases here like this one.
Notice that this was is a c four h nine
and this one is also c four h nine so
here's a primary and a secondary which
differ by 20 kilocalories per mole in the
gas phase.
And that really does show that
secondary is more stable than primary.
But this table definitely doesn't show
that secondary vinyl cat ions are more
stable than primary vinyl cat ions.
So you have to think carefully about
compared to what here you're comparing two
different numbers of Adams
in their standard states,
not relative to each other,
nor are relative to their
respective starting materials
or products as we talked
about last time.
So this table in general is irrelevant
to the question of I and stability in the
sense that we were talking
about it in the previous slide.
Now on the other hand,
and it allowed near table 4.2 gives
the heats of formation of ISO Merrick,
butyl cad ions,
right?
So the same atoms they're being
compared to the same thing.
So differences between them now do
tell us the difference between primary,
secondary, and tertiary cat ions.
So here are the, here are the,
they got it from the same numbers,
heats of formation,
although in fact you'll find that these
numbers are slightly different from
those in the previous table. So one, one,
neither books says what the source
of these numbers is. So, uh,
these NIST values have been pretty
carefully gone through. So if I,
if push comes to shove, I often look
at those or ask Professor Weinberg,
what's the best value is okay.
But here you see that that uh,
the relative energy of the
tertiary beautiful cat ion is,
is taken a zero,
the most stable and now the others
are 16 or 32 or 37 kilocalories,
a less stable,
right?
So tertiary is more stable than
secondary is more stable than primary.
And here are two different primaries.
Now if we look at that too,
those two,
we see that going from primary
to secondary is a heat of,
is a difference of 21
kilocalories per mole.
37 to 16 primary is,
is less stable by 21
kilocalories per mole, okay?
Now remember that the reason for this
could be things like hyper conjugation or
the number of carbons bonded to
the SP squared carbon, right?
The same factors that we talked about
in the case of alkenes making more
substituted owl Keaton's more stable here,
more substituted cad ions are more stable,
but the difference is much bigger here.
21 kilocalories per mole versus two
and a half kilocalories per mole.
From the slope of that plot we made
for the alkenes at the beginning of the
lecture.
So it's ever so much more important for
cad ions than it is for alkenes whatever
the factor is that's doing this. Okay.
So it could be hyper conjugation.
Would you expect that to be more stable,
more important for the cat ions shown
here or for the alkenes where the carbon
is carbon carbon double bond.
You have the same factor that the carbon
carbon double bond here would have a
low Lubo. This has, uh, that, uh,
p orbital on carbon that has a Pi star,
orbital Alo Lumo and the same deal here.
Right.
Would you expect the, the, uh,
effect of that mixing Homo Lubo mixing
in hyper conjugation to be the same as,
as when you have a double bond,
which would be if one is bigger than the,
once that stabilization as bigger than
the other, which, so here we have,
uh,
here we have the electrons in a sigma
bond and here we have a vacant orbital.
In the case of the cat aisle,
we have just a vacant p orbital.
In the case of the double bond,
we have Pi star orbital,
right plus minus,
which one's going to give more
stabilization of these electrons?
What determines that?
What determines how much stabilization
you get out of mixing horribles there you
good
overlap is one thing now,
so it's a p orbital on carbon in either
case here in one case that p orbital is
also associated with another PR battle.
So each of them is one over the square
root of two, so it's smaller in one case.
So there deed would be less
overlap in the case of of uh,
of the carbon carbon double bond rather
than just a full fledged p orbital.
So that's one factor. How
about another factor, Reagan?
How about the energy match
when you have a positive,
think about that carefully.
Say that again. Yeah.
The positive charge,
it makes the energy fabulously low
for the cad ion. The Pi's stars is,
is low compared to sigma star,
but it's not really all that low
compared to the vacant orbital.
So both on the basis of overlap
and on the basis of energy match,
you expect a much bigger factor for
the cat I and the data for the alkene.
And in fact, that's what you see. It's
worth a heck of a lot more, right? Uh,
and but the bond energy factor might
be more or less similar between the two
because in both cases you're
changing c h DSCC single bonds.
But this is the one that should
make a really big difference.
But there's another
factor as well actually,
which is that these are
measured in the gas phase.
Alright?
So we have this positively charged
carbon in the gas phase in,
so we saw when we talked about the
ionization of water, how much difference,
how much of a effect salvation
has on the ability to form ions.
So here we're trying to form an
eye and on this carbon, right?
Could you see something that,
another difference among
about stables, about stabilization
by this positive charge,
other than hyper
conjugation and bond energy
haven,
it's the other stuff in the molecule.
The other three carbon atoms in there,
hydrogens are polarizable.
But remember that there's a
very strong distance dependence.
You have to be really close to get
a lot of advantage out of that.
So with t butyl,
you have all the other atoms really
close to the positive charge to be
stabilized by polarization here. Uh, here,
you have that one much further away.
Here you have two of them
significantly further away.
And here you have this one
And this one off in left field,
right?
So we can see that there's
going to be in trauma,
molecular salvation that you might call
it, that nobody else calls it that.
But this effect from polarizability that's
going to in the gas phase is going to
be very important. But if you go
into solution, it's just the reverse,
right? Because the, the,
the one that the primary one up
here has the positive charge,
very exposed. So neighboring
molecules can get very close to that.
So in the gas phase,
it's the molecules within,
that's the Adams within the molecule
that are solid aiding the positive charge
and are electrons being stabilized.
But if you go into regular solution,
it turns around. So, so these, these, uh,
so these differences in the gas phase
are much bigger than the effects that you
would actually see in a solution reaction
where the primary car cad ions are
more stabilized by the surrounding
molecules. So for example, if you do sn,
one reaction t beautiful bromide is
only about five kilocalories per mole,
easier to ionize than ice appropriate
bromide that we saw in that,
that,
uh,
remember where a methyl ethyl
ice appropriate t butyl,
right?
T butyl was unusually easy to do to
substitute because it went by sn one,
right? But if you looked at
the ice of propyl, it also, uh,
was going partly by sn one.
And it turns out that it's about five
kilocalories harder for ice appropriately.
But here,
the difference between a t butyl and,
and ice and the ice of the,
the equivalent of ice
appropriately is, uh, is,
is 16 kilocalories per mole,
right?
Or even more so.
So it's very strongly
attenuated and solution. So, uh,
people often talk about gas phase being
intrinsic values for four things you
could measure like the heats of formation
of these things that that's the ideal.
The reason it's ideal is you could
compare it with calculation, right?
But it's not an ideal reference if
what you're interested in is predicting
reactions and solution where
that salvation is going to
make a lot of difference.
Okay. Now here's addition of, uh,
of Hcl to an Alkane.
Okay.
So is this mark off in the car
for Anti Markovnikov addition?
Natalie, what? Do you remember
what mark called [inaudible]?
Have you mark off the cough means?
Okay.
Does the an eye on the non hydrogen thing
go to the more substituted carbon in
this case? Yeah, it
did. And why? Of course,
what we would expect is that
it would be attacked. Right?
And this would give the more substituted
cad I on rather than attacking the
central carbon and having the primary
cad I is the intermediate, right?
Then chloride goes over and forms a
new bond and you have the product.
So that's Mark Hoffman a
cough edition by however,
that's only 17% of the product.
The 83% of the product is that.
Can anybody see what's funny about that
product is that the anti Markovnikov
addition,
Natalie,
awesome.
Right?
I can't hear very well that part
of it is equally substituted.
Ah,
the, the substitution of the carbons
is different. What has happened,
we saw this before,
Chris will shit,
a vessel is shifted.
It's rearranged. In fact,
what shifts is a muscle group,
but it's a methyl with its electrons.
It's a meth.
I'd shift that. What you're talking
about, cad ions as you will see here.
So it's,
it's shifted the methyl across.
So what's happened is that
those pair of the electrons,
it's like hyper conjugation,
right?
That those sigma electrons are stabilized
by the vacant orbital on the carbon,
but they're stabilized so much
that the methyl with its electrons,
with those bonding electrons,
the method shifts across. Right?
And often if you want
to have fun when you,
sometimes when you a rearrangement,
you pro draw a little loop in the
Arrow in that cute. Okay. So the,
the meth I'd has shifted across
to give this more stable cat I,
and this was secondary.
This one is tertiary. Okay.
And then that gives 83% of the product.
So what this says is that
the rearrangement, the Meth,
I'd shift competes with reaction
with the collapse of the ions,
chloride attacking the positive carbon.
So both things happen,
right?
And they have similar rates.
Now suppose you didn't have,
suppose you had a lot of
some other nucleophile.
They're like water right now.
The unshared pair of water could fill
the role that chloride filled here and
then lose protons that you've got h o t
a h two o plus than it loses a proton.
So you could get this alcohol or
you can get the rearranged alcohol.
So the fact of this
rearrangement is of course,
additional evidence that you had the cat
eye and intermediate as it was in a sn.
One reactions where, where the, uh,
rearrange skeleton showed that there
had been a cat eye and intermediate.
Uh, so when you do, uh, uh,
acid catalyzed hydration of a double bond,
addy,
h and o h,
uh,
you have to be aware that there's
the possibility of rearrangement.
If the skeleton is one where you
would form one cat ion, but then, uh,
uh,
some of method shift could get,
or a hydride shift could
give a more stable one.
Now let's look at the influence
of Halogen in, in these, uh,
cat ions.
So here we start with
a settling and at Hcl,
right?
So we've started to give the
more substituted vinyl cad ion.
Remember the table we talked,
it said primary vinyl cat ions are less
stable than secondary vinyl cat ions,
even though the data didn't, was not
the appropriate data to support that.
It's absolutely true that vinyl
cat ions are very hard to make,
right? So this is not such an easy
process, but then it can add chloride.
So you have, uh, this, uh, this product,
which is the Markovnikov product,
the,
the Proton added to the terminal carbon
to make the more stable secondary rather
than adding to the central carbon to
make the less stable primary cad. I,
and so the chloride ends up there and
this is perfectly reasonable. Okay.
But it went by way of
this unstable vinyl cad I,
and so it turns out that this,
that audition, this kind of, uh,
electrophilic addition to alkenes is a
hundred to a thousand times slower than
it to alkanes is 102 party to al kinds
is a hundred to a thousand times slower
than to alkenes.
It's much harder to add to triple bonds
the double bonds because you get these
unfavorable vinyl cat high
and intermediate. Well, fine,
but now we have a double
bond. Okay, so you could do,
and we had Markovnikov for ego chemistry,
but you,
if you have excess hcl you can,
you can add it again and yet
a second Markovnikov addition.
Okay.
Uh,
now suppose you didn't
have an excess of HCL.
Suppose you just had
one equivalent of HCL.
What products would you expect?
What products would you expect to get
Jack? Pardon? It's still bad.
Why still that
double bond?
The double bond is easier to
attack from the triple bond.
So if you didn't have enough hcl,
still this would be much more reactive
than this. After you formed any of that,
it will be reacting a hundred
to a thousand times faster
per molecules and that
did, so you're still going to get
this product Jack's right. Okay.
Uh, now these were on under certain
conditions. These are the, uh,
the yield you got.
It was 56% and 44%.
I suspect that if the reaction
had been carried on longer,
you would get do what Jack did. You
get, well, you'd go all the way there,
but under certain conditions at least
the reaction was interrupted and that was
the product distribution.
Now it went obviously by way of
this cat eye and intermediate.
The second step protonated
to give this substituted cat.
Now we have a question.
Is the halogen as a substituent favorable
or unfavorable for purposes of forming
the cad?
I am.
Okay.
Jack helped us out again here.
What does this say was this seconds,
was the second step what you
expected it to be in terms of rate?
Is it usually faster, unusually
slow compared to what you expected?
Fast slow.
What did you say before you
said the product that this
should react to a hundred
to a thousand,
be in a double bond,
should react to a hundred to a
thousand times faster than this.
Did it react to 100,000, a
hundred to a thousand times? No,
it didn't react any faster at all.
Right? Or roughly the same. Right.
So for some reason this was
slowed down by, you know,
some, several powers of 10, right?
What could have slowed it down?
Exploring?
It could be because of the chlorine.
It could be hard to stay to get a cat.
I did that.
Would that make sense to you?
Why? Cause the, uh, has a lecturer.
Now the question is how hard is
it going to be to form this cat?
I'd write that which was was, which we
did by putting a proton on that carbon,
right? The alkene carbon gets
a proton, gets that cat eye it.
So is it harder that Sebastian,
what do you say?
What effect do you think the chlorine,
sorry.
The sigma bonds is electron withdrawing,
right?
Fewer the electrons around the carbon
are lower in energy because they've been
sucked away by the chloride,
so it's harder to form the cad ions.
So that's what we, that that would
explain why we get this ratio here.
Okay.
That this second step,
even though it's an alkene and
should be enormously faster,
is not any faster because this chlorine
slowing it down by pulling electrons
away. It can't provide electrons
to the Proton. Now Sebastian,
keep going for us.
How about the regio chemistry?
So the second step is slow, right?
That's what we were just talking about.
How about the regio
chemistry of the second step,
and this isn't Markov in
the Coffer Anti Markovnikov
that is the proton could have added here
to give this cat ion or it could have
added to the central carbon to give
the other cat island, which did it do.
Did the new chlorine go on?
The more substituted or the less
substituted other more substitutes.
So it,
the chlorine slows it down,
but it's still Markovnikov this cat die
and is better to get than the other cad
I am,
yes.
Right now you might
say,
Aha,
the choice here is between a secondary,
whatever the chlorine is and a
primary and primaries are bad to get.
You don't want to protonate the set in
the center of one cause it'd be a primary
cad ion.
But notice here with Hbr when
it the outlet symmetrical,
right? Still the two bro
means go to the same place.
So the, it looks like the chlorine
is welcoming the formation of a cad.
I am or the at least bromine in this case
as welcoming formation of that cad ion
rather than cat I in it then that cat
ion and add in the second proton. Right?
So the answer is yes.
Right?
Is it favorable or
unfavorable? It's both, right?
It's hard to make the cat eye and
because of the single sigma electron
withdrawal, but if you form the cad
ion, where do you want to form it
next to the chlorine? Why
Chris? Do you have an idea?
If you're going to get a car,
if you're forced to make a cat eye.
And he say in this case when you put that
second bromine and you could have made
the cat eye on either here or here,
both of them with respect to the carbon
would be secondary. But this one,
the one you actually form where the
bromide comes in has a bromine on it.
Why? It's hard to form it, right?
Because of the sigma bonds
or electron withdrawing.
But if you form it format
next to the bromine, why
it makes it even more.
The polarizability is a good point and
that wasn't what I was thinking of,
but it's a good point.
What else?
Lone pairs on the halogen can be
stabilized by overlapping, right?
So you get resonance stabilization.
So if you're going to make it,
make it where you can get
help in the Pi system. Okay.
So that's really I think interesting about
about the halogens that they could be
deactivating but still want to have the
cat eye and next to them because of the
different role of the sigma electrons
and the pile electrons. Okay.
Thanks for sticking around here.